I didn't know that one out of every two
fish was farmed instead of caught our
culture has been is just repeating the
patterns of the wild which is feeding
small fish to big fish you know they go
out and catch 20 million tons a year of
herring and anchovy and menhaden these
little bony oily fish they grind them up
and press them out into a fat ingredient
called fish oil and a protein ingredient
called fish meal and those are
commodities that are internationally
traded and those are the key ingredients
to make alcohol to feed so that's how
you get these special proteins and oils
that these marine creatures require to
be healthy fish meal has the price band
of fish Mill has more than doubled and
it's gone up between five and six acts
since 1995 we like dirty co2 because
that's cheap or people might pay us to
take it and in our bacteria you could
say eat or remediate a lot of the things
that the EPA is actually concerned about
these bacteria that can take the co2 and
use the hydrogen and grow the proteins
in those bacteria are intentionally very
similar to the proteins of the small
fish that the big fish eat in the wild
puts off about 1.2 million tons a year
of co2 we could make 600,000 tons a year
of our nuovo meal from that
[Music]